need motivation watch a top 10 would
believe nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you as well you've got Michael Jordan
level talent add something so get ready
to get addicted to success think bigger
and scale with Grant Cardone and my take
on this top 10 rose to success vol 19
joy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
1 get addicted to success they're gonna
tell you like they told me and I
believed it for a while I did but I
didn't is look you're a drug addict you
can't help it you're powerless it's in
your genetic code and you have no
control over it now I'm gonna tell you
right now that I believe that to be a
complete complete garbage your loss so
if I was a drug addict and it's
completely out of my control then I
would have had to use drugs today yeah
and I didn't so using drugs as a choice
yeah I would tell you and I would tell
everybody that that has that addictive
nature is congratulate yourself and pat
yourself on the back that you have the
ability to be addicted to something and
take that addiction do it and put it
into something unbelievable because
every every super successful person that
I have studied and/or met it is has the
ability to be obsessed with something to
the point of losing sleep yeah to the
point of I don't need to need to eat
I'll go in debt
I'll go bankrupt I'll go down with the
ship to make this thing happen and
that's really what turned my whole life
around was just flipping the addiction
not trying to not be in control not
trying to turn it all over just saying
hey I'm gonna take this energy and I'm
gonna dump it into into work rule number
two
advertise you gotta advertise and you
gotta spend money on marketing and
advertising if you if people don't know
you it will cost you
fortune it cost me four hundred million
dollars over the last twenty years
because I was not spending money in
marketing and promotion and advertising
and social media actually thought social
media didn't work I was so wrong about
that I started a social media company
well we actually now run ads for
companies so that you get known the way
I've gotta know today with I don't know
a million one point four million
Instagram followers a million
subscribers on YouTube that's six
million people on Facebook trust me if
you don't advertise on social media I
would call you a Dumbo you know why I
had the right to because I didn't think
it worked either rule number three take
care of yourself first all people men
and women they should be more greedy
about their personal dreams what'd they
say - five kids and I've got this
responsibility and yeah you do but you
also have a responsibility yourself like
how can i if I can't take care of me how
can I take care of somebody else yeah
this has always been my battle cry like
I have to take care of me you know and
and how can I help anyone I'm broken a
messed up you know I'm coming out of a
treatment center for drug addiction I
didn't need to help anybody else I
needed to get I needed to get on solid
ground you know I needed to make sure I
wasn't going back to treatment and then
I needed to clean up the mess that I
mean I needed to do this for me because
and that has been my contention now for
many years like just keep slowly taking
care of your neighborhood until you're
in another zip code rule number four
improve your network they say your
network equals your net worth your
ability to move this planet to change
things to get investors funding money is
determined by who you know if you got a
money problem I guarantee it's got
something do with your network okay if
you if you're having marriage problems I
assure you
with 100% certainty if you're having
marriage problems there's somebody and
your
network their believes in marriage
problems if you're having kiddie
problems you know not kitty-kitty
you know I'm talking about you've got
problems with your kids it's because
your network is having problems with
chilling if you have a time problem I
don't have enough time I can't find
enough time I'm working too hard I never
have time I can't find time to work out
can't find time for the kids I can't
find time for the marriage you have a
network of people that have time
problems also if you want to have more
confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links to join are in
the description below I've been at a
point in my life where I thought I
thought less than me then anyone thought
of me how many have been there
my dreams are first everyday then my
wife they're my kids I could take care
of my wife and my kids now would you
agree I abandoned this this is the fuel
for Who I am
you have to go build self-confidence
rule number five scale I thought I
thought people cost money none of these
people cost anything okay do you know
that only 4% of companies in America
make a million dollars a year 67% of all
companies in America have no employees
okay so if you stay with no employees
and you're the only person working there
promise you will not make money less
than 4% of all companies in America make
million dollars each rule number six
think bigger when I was in McDonald's
and I got fired from McDonald's flipping
burgers are true the fries or what were
you doing whatever they had me did they
had me they had me do what you know
there this is what we do right
it's a road it's a factory and I was 16
years old and and my dad had been dead
six years so like you know like I'm
uncertain 15 60 I've just had sex for
the first time everything is so
complicated making five bucks an hour
that's why whatever was no it's probably
like 280 Wow you know but that wasn't
that did that wasn't the problem
I was grateful for the 280 but I was
awkward I was not confident I didn't
know how to talk to people yeah yeah I
hated the job
but if somebody who said to go learn
this game so you can own 50 McDonald
restaurants and like if I would have had
that that idea
I bet you I would own a bunch of
McDonald franchises today but I went
there just for the 280 yeah not not for
hey I want to do something I think I
truly think that the the thing that I've
suffered from the most in my life and I
look at Kobe and you know all these
pictures these great people you know did
I just thought too small I was worried
about the 80 bucks and I was worried
about what the car dealers thought about
me that audience rule number seven
focused on income not expenses was I was
bought I was managing the bottom half of
my financial statement not the top one
inch today I spend 95% of my time on the
top Lilly inch inch and a half and I
ignore the rest I might spend three
percent of my time on managing expenses
and cost and budgets I spend ninety five
percent of my time on the income of the
company on how to increase the income
how to blow up the top line let's see if
they even let me in the office yeah how
to blow the top line in hopes that I
could spend more money in marketing
spend more money in brandy it's been one
money employees rule number eight know
your strengths and weaknesses I don't
think I was built to be quiet like like
they tell you when you were growing up
you know be quiet be seen not heard or
be the hurt whatever they do is you know
don't touch own horn don't get too much
attention and don't promote yourself and
but look man God was a showoff' man look
what he created just did stop he's not
quiet no ok rainbows
you know Suns planets like waterfalls
everything you're crazy man I think we
love people that are grateful and have
humility but we also love to see people
do great things
yeah is there a balance that they should
have like also be grateful and humble as
opposed to kind of like that
McGregor dude I love McGregor yeah see I
like that that's your that's your energy
you like your on that frequency I you
know
who doesn't like it look at that big the
audience is you know look at the rock he
don't have little muscles right but he's
he's got more humility let's say a jerk
oh he knows how that he knows that I was
like that game oh my god I mean there's
nobody better than a rock at that Obama
was unbelievable with that yeah it
staying connected that's what I'm
terrible at I'm awful at I am so bad at
it why I don't know why I don't know why
I just know I'm bad at it
rule number nine focus on the money I
don't want to talk to you about
execution and management and business
planning and culture I want to talk to
you about money because money we believe
is the number one problem in your
business it's not mission it's not
purpose it's not all these beautiful
things everybody tells you it's not
planning and organizing I have seven
businesses there's seven little
companies there's been no plant there's
been minimal organizing tremendous speed
it's tremendous speed to market okay
it's one of the things that that has
made us successful but mostly in all the
businesses every business was created
around the concept it needs to make
money
[Music]
because if it doesn't make money
you'll call yourself an entrepreneur
[Music]
because you're not to be able to call
yourself businessperson and so this
industry of entrepreneurs that that is
now so popular I never even knew the
term until like a year and a half ago
okay before that I was in California
somebody said I was an entrepreneur 15
years ago I'm like well that's that's
code for I don't have a job okay
today today look if you want to be an
entrepreneur good but really what you
want to do is evolve to being a business
person that makes money and that
provides a good living for a lot of
other people right so number one problem
in your business is employee
disengagement it is not actually money
money is their problem
employee disengagement how many of you
here own a runner Department let me see
if you run or manage more than more than
just yourself let me see him how many of
you here run or manage a household okay
good well if you can't manage the
household by the way you have
disengagement at a household level would
you agree husband and wife are
disengaged ones doing their own plan
this one's doing their plan 50% of those
marriages are gonna fail okay that's
what they say they're gonna divorce
truth is way more than 50% fail people
should not be looking at the divorce
rate they should be looking at the
failure rate and rule number 10 the last
one before very special bonus clip is be
a winner there is no shortage of success
regardless of their culture race
religion economic background or social
group most people would agree that
success is vital to the well-being of
the individual the family
and the group and certainly to the
future survival of all these things look
without success your group your company
your goals and dreams and even the
entire civilization would cease to
survive and thrive winning over and over
again and everything in which you're
involved ensures you're gonna be able to
further expand and survive and it
guarantees that both you and your ideas
will survive not just get by but survive
into the future
if you quit caring then you're gonna
quit winning and if you quit winning
long enough in this thing called success
you're gonna just plain quit how would
being successful being Partin to you and
how would it improve your life look
success is needed in order to perpetuate
to push forward people places and things
you must never reduce success in your
mind or in a conversation to something
that doesn't matter
on the contrary you must treat successes
though it's vital it's important any one
that minimizes the importance of success
to your future has probably given up on
his or her own chances of accomplishment
and is spending now his or her life
trying to convince others you in this
case to also give up individuals and
groups must actively accomplish their
goals and targets in order to carry on
with their goals and targets if not look
they'll either cease to exist or be
consumed and become part of something
else it's not enough just to play the
game it's vital you learn how to win at
this game now I've got a special bonus
tip from Grant on how to be a strategic
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go
question number one where do you need to
take care of yourself first number two
what's the thinking bigger version of
your goals and number three how are you
going to improve your network this week
also if you like this video and you're
gonna take action after watching a gimme
a hashtag believe down in the comments
as well when I was trying to go from 30
and I remember when I was making 30 gram
when I tried to go from 30 to a hundred
I just ended up with all the same
problems you know it's like okay I'm
making 30 let's say I'm making pies I'm
making pies and I'm making 30 pies it's
the same thing by the way same
restrictions a physical universe I don't
have enough time I don't have enough
dough I don't have enough ovens so the
guys like I'm gonna go from 30 to 100
well you can't do that in the space
you're in so you need a bigger space but
you don't have the money for a bigger
space so the trick is to create a plan
around going from 30 to 300 not a
hundred because the people are trying to
edge into them I'm gonna go from thirty
to forty forty to fifty fifty to sixty
but what they should do is put a plan to
go from thirty to three hundred because
immediately you'll be like I can't do it
in my kitchen anymore
I need more ovens I need more money I
need help
immediately it unlocks you from this
budget this this mentality that trap is
so long
if you want more grant cardone and check
out the top 50 rules video I made on him
the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there if you're
not going to work like a 10-hour day as
a short day for me I hear more people
promoting this for our idea